ces derniers jours Bruno les intérêts
russes continuent donc à être visés oui
visiblement on est dans une stratégie
alors soit de l'Ukraine soit de groupe
russes anti-putine c'est aussi une
possibilité
en tout cas il y a ces tiers de drones
en territoire russe jusqu'à Moscou ce
matin on l'évoquait donc à l'instant
dans un territoire russe qui a été
conquis en 2014 dans le bon base dans
cette région de Louhans que toujours
est-il que c'est pas tellement à part ce
qui s'est passé à Louandre puisque là il
y a eu des morts mais sinon les attaques
de drone même à Moscou bon ça fait pas
des dégâts énormes mais c'est les dégâts
psychologiques c'est le fait que la
confiance de la population russe soit un
peu ébranlé visiblement c'est ça
l'objectif qui est cherché et qui met de
fait un peu la direction russe et
Vladimir Poutine dans une position un
peu délicate parce qu'ils savent pas
trop comment riposter d'où cet effet à
la fois de minorer ce qui s'est passé
et de dire que la défense anti-aérienne
russe a parfaitement fonctionné Vladimir
Poutine il est actuellement dans une
position difficile parce que non
seulement il s'attend à la contrefaite
ukrainienne donc il mène leur stratégie
militaire avec les bombardements sur
Kiev mais en interne en fait il est
contesté quand même peut-être par ces
groupes prorus il y a aussi visiblement
il y avait gagné prigogi le patron de
Wagner qui veut jouer un peu sa carte et
vis-à-vis de sa population
il doit faire très attention parce que
s'il y a des attaques contre la
population que la guerre cette guerre
cette opération spéciale comme la plé
Vladimir Poutine qui était loin pour les
Russes si elle devient concrète et si
les Russes constatent que la manière de
défendre leurs intérêts n'est pas
suffisante là ça peut provoquer un fort
mécontentement de la part de la
population russe et face